each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay I'd like to thank the organizers
for giving me the opportunity to speak
about the shared genomics project which
is a project coming out of the northwest
institute for my health informatics of
the University of Manchester and it's a
project whose aim is to try and engage
clinical scientist with even
infrastructure so basically we're trying
to get allow clinical scientists medics
people working with with patients are
allowing them to analyze their genetic
data and as I explained you know that
that but requires developing an hpc
solution or and codes that we can we can
paralyze but a along with that we've got
to make the hole in access to the whole
system and the yeah an interpretation of
the results you know easy for art for
our end users ok so the outline of the
talk first of all are sort of talk a bit
about this sort of genetic data that
we're dealing with for specifically
genome-wide snip datasets snips single
nucleotide polymorphism data sets so
single changes in a DNA sequence
genome-wide so we're looking at changes
many positions within it within the
genome then have to be talking about the
a the actual hpc platform that we've
actually developed and how we've gone
about trying to make it accessible to
our end users and then lastly I'll be
talking about the process of how we
actually also use e.e science
infrastructure to aid the interpretation
of the of the results I aid the
interpretation of the the results we're
getting from the statistical analysis
run on the HPC platform okay there's one
okay so to outline the scientific
problem okay you know our goal here as
the last speaker was was was was
mentioned is to identify the genetic
causes of disease so what we've got here
as an example DNA sequences of two
individuals one who has known one
individual who has normal vision and can
see the boy catching Lee the baseball
and another person who's got a blurred
vision as a result of diabetic
retinopathy the took the two sequences
the two genome sequences but of those
individuals are largely are largely the
same but there's a you know variations
at a particular site some of that
variation may actually contribute to the
reasons why that person with the with
the lower genome has it has blurred
vision the trouble is okay which of
those changes is responsible which of
those changes may be contributing to the
disease condition okay you can imagine
you know fairly simple ways in which we
could we could elucidate the an answer
to that question we just get a the
genomes from a load of people with with
normal vision and genome sequences from
a load of people with diabetic
retinopathy and compare and contrast so
it's a relatively simple process we can
go through to actually try and work out
where some of those genetic positions
which lead to the disease might lie the
only problem is is the scale of the
calculations that we're working with so
modern biotechnology allows us to
actually study of order of half a
million nowadays probably a million
different positions in the genome
different low site within the within the
genome so basically we're trying to work
out which out of half a million
different positions could be
contributing to the actual disease
condition and it's not even that simple
unfortunately often some of the
conditions we're looking at or we're
interested in may be the result of not
just one change in a DNA sequence but
multiple changes acting in concert or or
interacting so if we if we want to do a
systematic analysis of all the possible
pairs of changes which might lead to the
disease condition well if we're starting
with half a million individual positions
then by tomor
it appears we're talking of order of 10
to the 11 pairs so to analyze it in any
any sort of systematic way or even even
a sizable fraction of that 10 to 11
would would require a substantial amount
of compute power and then lastly
actually a lot of a lot of the sort of
diseases we're interested in particular
collaborators are interested in our may
be the result of gene environment
interactions the disease condition may
not just be due to it maybe have a
genetic component but that genetic
component is modified by the environment
the exposures the individual was a grew
up in or exposed to for example a
tickler person may have a particular a
particular mutation but if they've also
grown up and say a dusty household that
may also increase their their their
their likelihood of developing asthma
trying to understand these complex gene
environment interactions and then the
genetic part of the disease genetic
component of the disease really requires
a you know a domain knowledge of the
disease condition processing the data
ruling is going to require compute power
so we've got this difficult sort of
situation where one did when it can have
to develop high you know may use of
large amounts of compute power but the
people who are going to interpret the
results are going to be people have got
domain expertise got a detailed
knowledge of the actual condition so
what we're going to try and do is allow
the people to understand the condition
name in the clinical scientists to
actually directly use the the HPC
capability that we're developing okay
just to reinforce the scale of the scale
of the task you can imagine our data
might be you know laid out and some
simple data data sort of grid like a
spreadsheet where we got individual
genetic positions or snips in rows and
patients in the columns the sorts of
algorithms we might run to actually
identify an individual genetic position
might be a relatively simple low
complexity calculation represented by
this in a loop here for example it may
just be a looping over the that the
patient sample we've got an identifying
you know doing simple counts of the num
if people have got the disease and the
number of people who haven't so we're
talking relatively simple calculations
but on top of that we're repeating it
for obviously the number of different
you know genetic locations we're
interested in and then and so so
immediately we've got a larger
calculations and if we're looking at
pairs of snips this is also going to be
a much large and I'm were talking about
snip pairs here and then finally what
would another another layer of
complexity to add on top of that is that
we may actually want to repeat the whole
calculation for a number of randomized
data sets per muted data sets in order
to get a measure of statistical
significance so what started out as a
very simple calculation here which may
be taking the order a fraction of a
second maybe then repeated half a
million times or even larger and then
possibly over many random randomized
data sets for example 10,000 randomized
data sets so we've got a large-scale cut
you know compute problem here and you
can immediately see areas where where
it's right for parallelization the low
complexity calculation here is
essentially our our single independent
task we can paralyze over the number of
snips on the number of randomized data
sets the world that they were interested
in and then finally another area of
complexity within the other than the
task is we actually need to understand
the statistical results so we can
develop an htpc platform to process the
data but if we don't understand the
results than then all we're going to do
is is take raw large volumes of raw data
and transform it into even larger
volumes of process data which is no use
to our end users so what we actually
need to do is we need to add relevant
biological information to the data we
need to put those to the score results
in a context our end users can
understand and that will enable them to
actually make the insights that their
domain knowledge you know what will you
know will help them to do so what we're
actually going to do is we're going to
annotate the statistical results with
relevant biological information such as
you know positions on the genome okay
I'll see the contrary the communities
which are going to contribute to the
sort of work we're doing come in when a
free main flavors if you like there's
the clinical scientists to actually
bring the domain expertise the knowledge
of the disease
and new ways of thinking about analyzing
the data there they'll suggest ways in
which you know we know the ways of
looking the data that that statisticians
may not have you know necessary for Tov
then we've got software engineers or so
you're doing a lot of the infrastructure
development coding of the HPC analysis
codes and barfing morticians who are
suggesting new algorithms that need
coding up or also suggesting third-party
resources that we might need use to to
annotate the statistical results and we
can also look at the actual problem in
another way and that's to break it down
into the free tasks so one of the dinner
that the free task being how do we
provide a nice accessible sort of way in
a interface for if there are clinical
users to access this this platform
there's the actual developing of the HPC
platform itself and writing of the
statistical analysis codes and then
finally how do we help win the
interpretation of this discourse
statistical results and the way we do it
is we're going to annotate the results
the statistical results using web
services I were going to try and
automate that process as much as
possible and indeed that that annotation
process you know it froze up metadata
which is you know it by definition by
being data is it we can also you know
analyze and do some secondary analysis
of so what I'm going to do for the rest
of the talk is sort of go through these
individual stages starting off with the
the the the first one where our goal is
to actually provide a simple front end
for allowing our clinicians to do a PC
on that on the on the genetic data key
requirement as the last speaker mention
is is it's got to be easy to drive so
any interface it's got to be you know
relatively simple just providing Lee
there's sort of the the the options the
users expecting I you know the sort of
options that we've dropped down you know
going to be about the the algorithms
that they want what they want to apply
to the data all the HPC infrastructure
and the bioinformatics tools and that
we're going to use to annotate the data
have to be hidden from the user the job
submission details essentially have to
be you know all the gory details are
doing the HPC actually have to be a
hidden as much as possible
and then once the analysis is finished
what we're going to try and do or what
we do do actually as this sort of
example shows here is once we finish the
HPC analysis we load the data into into
a format that the users are familiar
with so most of our users will be
familiar with say you know office
applications you know spreadsheets like
Excel or they'll be familiar with
openoffice so what we're going to do is
we're going to present the data to them
in a spreadsheet grid so once we've done
the statistical processing what they see
they load up the data and they'll see
each each result in an individual row
and off the individual row they can
right click and get the annotation data
that we've retrieved using the web
services so that's that's the client
that we've developed that I users use
and it talks through to the to the HPC
analysis codes on the HPC task what
we've actually done is we've taken an
existing code base in this case plink
which is from Harvard and essentially
we've cleaned it up and then paralyzed
it we chose plink because a number of
our users or some of our users were
already familiar with fee that the code
base it was also written in C++ as you
know it wasn't a small it wasn't a
difficult step to actually get into a
form where we could easily paralyze it
we've done some cleaning up for example
removing use of the standard you know
calls to the standard template library
and then what we've got is we've got a
code base which is extremely efficient
and got a relatively small footprint and
then we paralyze it by adding in the
appropriate MPI calls we've actually
deployed it on our own cluster which is
running windows hpc Server 2008
currently our cluster has a hundred
calls on it actually throwing calls at
this sort of calculation is is actually
very worthwhile the the problems we're
dealing with here are embarrassingly
parallel as the sort of little schematic
I had on a previous slide showed the
there's there's a large amount of the
part you know there's there's two areas
where it's row right for parallelization
and so although it's embarrassingly
parallel you can actually seen at this
very little communication between
processing of different snips that
actually means that adding calls yields
benefits so what we've got here is a
plot of the speed-up gained by adding
extra cause to some to the processing of
some test data the test data has been
given to us from one of our
collaborators in Manchester and it's a
an arthritis data set and what this
shows is the speed up you get as you
have a number of cores for different
sizes of problems so what I've got here
is processing of a thousand snips in
black processing of two thousand snips
in red processing of three thousand
snips in green this is actually an
interaction calculation so this is well
we've actually looked at is the all the
snip pairs within those data sets so if
we're looking at a thousand snips that's
of order a million or half a million
snip pairs and so on you can see as you
have the number of cause you had caused
the speed-up goes up and then ultimately
saturates in you know cordance with
handles law but as the scale of the
problem increases that the point at
which it begins to saturate actually
it's delayed later and later so you know
but when we're looking at three thousand
snips we've got a good region where it's
actually linear adding causes is
yielding benefits so by time we get to
3000 snips we're talking about 90 you
know an estimate of from this data is
that our problem is about 99%
parallelizable the parallels of all
fractions are up to in a point 99 so you
know adding cause gives us a 30-percent
30 times speedup and to give you an
indication of that what that represents
in real time on a single core down here
that the calculation takes about an hour
so we're getting were speeding that in
that our calculation up by about a
factor of 30 and this is on a single
data set we're not doing any rat we're
not working with any randomized data
sets if I actually wanted to work with
random I'd say 10,000 randomized data
sets as well on a single core you know
i'll be talking of order of technet
possibly 10,000 hours worth of CPU time
so what adding calls does for is is it
obviously you know allows us to
calculations on shorter time scales it
also enables new calculations
calculations that we wouldn't have even
tried before simply because we didn't
have a computer available to us and
because of that it enables us to explore
the data in new ways we're not actually
afraid of making mistakes or if you know
we're not we're not afraid of actually
maybe you know trying out some hunches
on some on some you know new ways of of
you know looking at the data because
compute power is now essentially cheap
you know we we can we can try out a few
more scientific hypotheses okay then on
to the last part of those those free
tasks I mentioned that one of the key
tasks that we see or one of the few
things we think is key is it's putting
the statistical results in context I
want to annotate the results and we
annotate using web services why we'll
simply because there's a large number of
web services out it was in the bath mat
as community out there already and it
avoids us having to curate or you know
large you know databases of biological
information we can we can annotate our
results for example we can you know we
can find out which you know if a
particular snip is in a gene we can find
out what gene it then what gene that is
we can find out what the you know any
putative function of that gene we can
find out that information very quickly
if the underlying that information about
a gene changes we're not responsible for
that we you know we're not we're not
involved in the curation game we can
just rely upon the providers of the
services to do that for to keep their
services up to date for us and as I said
before you know a lot of services are
already collected you know together in
workflow so they already do the sorts of
tasks we're interested in so for example
taverna workflows and therefore we can
just use those workflows to do you know
to do what we want just to say about
that the nature of the annotation data
that we're getting back in it in a lot
of cases it's textual it's things like
publications it might be on to you know
finding out the other the ontology terms
used to describe a gene for example go
terms it might be a list of
biochemical pathways that a particular
gene is involved in sometimes it may
actually be what I've called here
secondary computations so for example we
may provide you know Benchley providing
the user with you know if we're looking
at a snip which corresponds to an onsen
honest exchange we may be interested in
providing the user with an estimate of
how destabilizing thats that changes
upon the on the on the protein structure
so the actual annotation may be the
result of a secondary scientific
calculation and it may not just be you
know textual data that we're providing
whether we're annotating our original
statistical results with ok so give an
example what we've got here is a Taverna
workflow which will take a non trajan ID
so we've mapped already from the the RS
number the snip RS number to an entree
gene ID and then this workflow will map
from the entree gene ID to gear gives
the list of pathway you know if it's it
if the if they've snips in the middle of
a in a gene or give the list of pathways
the genes involved in and also grab a
load of any publications with in PubMed
that are associated associated with that
that that entre gene ID and again this
is a good example of a reuse of other
people's work this is a Taverna workflow
that we got from a workflow repository
my experiment and we just tweaked it
slightly to ought to our needs and what
happens is when the user actually loads
up a set of results that that have come
from the HPC analysis as the results are
loaded this the workflow is called and
it retrieves the list of publications
and then that list of publications is
available to the user on under the right
click so the user is actually completely
unaware of the fact that the workflow
has been
you know executed all they see as their
results in the grid they right-click and
they've got a list of publications
available to them the annotation as i
said is is is data we can do things with
that we can mine the annotation data for
for patterns i mean this is standard
practice in bio firm attics you might
look if you're looking if you're looking
at say for example gene expression data
is common to look for perhaps in
enrichment of go terms maybe pathways
are of all other functional descriptions
or descriptors of your genes so what we
can do this with the we can do it take
is very similar approach with the sort
of annotation data that we're getting
back from from that from the workflows
and again our goal is to do this
automatically if I doing this
automatically the user isn't aware of it
but what we're doing is we're providing
with the end user with clues and cues
about what the the particular snip
they've the the the statistical analysis
is that identified we're giving them
cues about what you know the biological
mechanism that might be you know what
you know the leading to the actual
disease so we're giving we're giving our
end users or helping them with it we
know what aiding them in interpreting
with statistical results just to give
you a very simple example what we do
with the publications that we get back
from that previous work for that i
showed the Taverna work throw that gets
the public list of publications from
pubmed for us what we actually do is we
take those lists of publications and we
feed them into a text mining web service
term line and turn mine essentially
breaks the article titles down into
words and then has a go at identifying
technical terms within that assigning a
a likelihood to we each were the
likelihood of it being a technical term
so when we display the the the read the
publication lists to the user what we do
is we we color code the the the words
according to their likelihood of a term
of a particular word being a technical
term and then we also display them in
rank order according to the overall or
the term likelihood within it within it
within the article title so what we got
at the top is largely articles which are
you know containing the words colored in
red and blue red and orange and then
towards the bottom we've got more
articles which are containing
it's highlighted in blue which is the
lower quarter olives of technical term
significance if the user wants to they
can click on an individual row and all
ll open up the abstract for them as well
so if they want to read a bit more about
a particular article article they can
click on it get the abstract and
there'll also be a hyperlink to the
actual original source or at least the
pub the PubMed entry and what we've done
here is a fairly simple ranking based
upon a what what the term I on web
service is getting back to us but
essentially we could rank in any way we
wanted to we might rank according to the
the year of the jury in the year of
publication the impact factor of the
journal citation count of the article
essentially we're only limited by the
services that are available to us it's
up to us you know if a services
available we can make use of it to
rangam make make suggestions to the user
ok what that sort of indicates that that
sort of automatic process of sort of
suggesting views on the data or
suggesting ways in which to interpret
the data is is a you know what we think
is important about the whole whole whole
platform what we're trying to do is
build a platform which provides thinking
space to our end-users it's not just a
question of processing data and then
providing them with a spreadsheet what
we actually wanted them to do is
actually you know we want to aid them in
in spotting in your new new scientific
hypotheses so we were trying to build a
platform enables them to think play and
also she may perhaps share ideas if you
share ideas although then you can
communicate them easily you to other so
what we want to do is provide a platform
that allows for rapid exploration of
ideas and then and then sharing them and
you know technology such as rich into
rich Internet applications may provide a
means for doing this so what we've tried
to do is and as an example is make use
of a silverlight component that grabs
also since she contains shots of the
analysis screens that the user generated
whilst they were looking at a particular
data set so if i click that and
hopefully what will happen is it will
produce a cover flow
sequence of images and what the images
consist of essentially what the what the
user has already looked at whilst
they've been whilst they've been
inspecting the the results in that in
that spreadsheet grid so that the users
been look you know specting lee the the
results from the HPC analysis they've
looked at some of the annotations and
now that now there are now they've
suddenly realized when it 10 minutes ago
there was something they they they
spotted it jobs something in their
memory or spark something off in their
in their way of thinking can they go
back and and and you know remember what
they what they did will have actually
sort of captured that in in in in visual
format with a bit of metadata describing
what it was that the user did or what
the image consists of so essentially
what we've got here is a visual history
of what the users done and I'll see we
can hyperlink and get that one to work
yeah we can you know provide hyperlinks
behind the images and the user can go
back to the original source if they want
to if they want to expand the view so it
may be that the image that you know that
they're actually looking at it's a good
aide memoire but it's not actually it's
not it has not sufficient detail what we
hope to do in the future is actually
allow users to edit perhaps some of
these these cover flows it may be a
situation where you've done half an
hour's worth of analysis you've got 30
or 40 images a lot of them may not be
very productive and then suddenly you
realize you stumble across an idea and
you want to communicate that idea to
your fellow colleagues which is the
ultimate motivation for the shared
genomics project what you could do is
maybe select four or five images which
sort of encapsulate your your your line
of argument your way of thinking and
then you can send that or allow your
your colleagues to access that cover
flow consisting of just the images that
you want them to see okay so go back to
okay future plans okay so that's just a
sort of snapshot of what we're trying to
develop one in the share genomics
platform our future plans well obviously
what we'd like to do is perhaps extend
the code base at the back end so the
main we've just got the one code base
that we've modified plink perhaps we
might use you know be you know we we aim
to reuse up some other code bases for
example our genetics in this case
probably not you know we're not we know
we're not we wouldn't customize in the
same way that we've customized a link to
our own ends obviously we want to extend
the app their list of annotations that
are available to the to the to the user
so again this woman you know mean making
extensive use of workflows which are
already in repositories so if we can
really go through repository such as my
experiment in there's a suitable
annotation workflow for which will give
us information about this you know about
snips then we can reuse that and make
the the annotations available to our end
user but I think the real key is perhaps
on how we present not only the
statistical data but also the annotation
data to the end use of visualization and
and and HCI are going to be key and
that's where the break fries are going
to come you know come through the rich
internet applications such as a
silverlight component may help we know
what we're exploring those ideas but
ultimately it's only really get a you
know work if we you maintain close
collaboration with our end users because
they're the ones suggesting novel ways
of viewing that interviewing the data so
we're trying to keep maintain a close
iterative cycle of you know of exploring
ideas and ways of viewing data with with
our end users so 2n I will just say
thanks to microsoft we're providing some
funding also our end users who provide
you know provide us with ideas and allow
themselves to be guinea pigs to try our
ideas on so we've got a number of users
from from local hospitals in the
Manchester area and then finally thanks
to the team in share dynamics mark mark
delafield the project manager and Ian
back on the the director of maybe are
both in the audience there's our website
I've got demos on my machine if you want
to see that coverflow example or the
actual workbench the other client
working and finally I thank you for
listening
okay we have time for a couple of
questions people produce the microphone
that would be great
hi so one friendly suggestion if I might
and then a question which is that the
cover flow application you're producing
one of the things that we've seen is
important for this kind of creative
synergy process is not just being able
to look back in time but being able to
juxtapose different parts of time so the
likelihood is it's something they've
seen now and something they were doing
10 minutes ago being if you can put
those together rather than having it
flipping through yeah might help okay
and the second thing along those lines
is that another feature that's often
forgotten from software like this that
turns out to be very useful is the
ability to just randomly spray ad hoc
tack store notations on to things
particularly if you're attempting to
communicate with another party so it's
not these five images it's these five
images and this annotation about what I
think of them that's completely
unstructured that turns out to be useful
yeah okay so on a related note of that
there seem to be two be two ways
generally to make sophisticated systems
easier to use the first is to hide all
of the complexity in do it by magic and
the second is to expose the complexity
through control to the end users you
seem to have been inclined towards the
first hiding the complexity away are
there any situations within your tool
where you think that exposing user
control is possibly the way to go in the
future um yeah I mean they did I mean as
our system grows then I think you know
we're going to you know perhaps some you
know hiding or complexity in all cases
is going to be it's going to be
difficult so for example as we add in
potentially more more code bases more
more more more options at different
algorithms to analyze the data I mean
that sushi in the last one situation
where we've got to you know open up
things to the user it's more as a
default
you know we yeah we do try and hide
things simply because some of our users
are coming from a background where
they're not bioinformatics religion and
there and they're not actually it's not
some of our users may not actually need
that familiar with all the new fiscal
genetics you know analysis details and
so we yeah we are we are making some
presumptions on on their behalf also it
allows us in some in some ways to free
up time to focus on the end part the
visualization which i think is actually
think the key is where where will make
the biggest gains for them and they
respond well to that and so far yes but
I think we have time for one more okay
in that case I'll ask I was wondering is
this software available for other labs
to use or do you have plans to make it
available and yes I mean maybe I want my
project manager won't Matt music
speaking and yet we do plan to roll it
out so what we've done so far it's just
roll it out to in the initial prototype
2 are sort of local user group I
friendly people looking to give a seat
back and maybe tolerate a few more a few
more bugs but yeah we do have plans to
release it and and make it widely
available though perhaps that the
biggest issue will be I'm at the moment
you know we've got a client and it's you
know connects 32 officer which runs that
runs the codes we don't know when we
might not to say make that completely
open it made me a question of you know
um you know within email us to request
in a correct request access and you know
that will be go through some process for
review yeah ultimately we do that I hope
to have you know a quite a wide
international user base okay thank you
very much